[Music]
a warm maori welcome at auckland airport
loved ones separated by the pandemic
finally reunited
with relief all
after the lifting of some of the world's
toughest border restrictions
oh incredible
i it's been a long long long
it's been two years in suspension of
just wondering if and when and never
knowing if the moment was even going to
come yeah it was looking pretty shaky
there we started without knowing if we'd
ever see each other
the vaccination of more than 80 percent
of the population led to the gradual
easing of the restrictions
we marked another big moment in our
reconnection with the world with our
borders reopening to visitors from visa
waiver countries welcoming again
tourists from the usa uk japan
germany canada korea and singapore
in addition those holding existing
visitor visas from any country in the
world can also travel here from today
citizens were first allowed to return
home in march followed by australians
last month and now expanded to 60 other
countries including many in europe
but travellers must be fully vaccinated
and have a negative pcr test visitors
from india china and other non-waiver
countries remain banned
the government hopes the using of travel
restrictions will help provide the
economy that relied heavily on the three
million tourists who visited annually
before the pandemic despite protests
against the strict lockdowns and limited
quarantine slots for kiwis stuck abroad
the government has credited the
relatively low covert death toll to its
strict no tolerance policy
and while the pandemic hasn't ended yet
life for many in new zealand is
returning to something like normality at
long last sarah
al jazeera